- Thank you for coming out
on your Friday afternoon
to learn more about RockEDU LAB Jumpstart.
And so my name is Odaelys Pollard.
I am the scientist-educator here
at RockEDU Science Outreach.
And I facilitate and manage
the LAB Jumpstart program
alongside some other
programming that we have
that engage with teachers,
scientists, and students.
With us on the webinar,
we have Lizzie as well,
who is our Program Coordinator.
And we also have a couple
other members of our team
who might join us later on.
And so our LAB Jumpstart program
has been around for a few years.
And we know because of
the current pandemic,
it may look a little different this year
than it did in past year.
So wanna give you all an overview
of what LAB Jumpstart is all about,
what are we looking forward to doing,
and what we expect from us, our students,
and the program on a whole.
So what is LAB Jumpstart?
So if you're not familiar,
the acronym LAB is actually
Learning at the Bench.
And LAB Jumpstart, we started about four,
about five years, five, six years ago now.
And so it's a combined after school
and summer science research
experience for students
who have not had a previous opportunity
to get their hands on to science research,
and who may have been interested,
but haven't been giving those leeway
to do things that they're interested
in terms of STEM and science.
And so what this program does,
it takes place after school,
this is all pre-pandemic,
and we met on Tuesdays and
Thursdays from 4:30 to 7,
and this would occur from March to June.
So there are two
components of the program.
There's a spring part and
then there's a summer part,
and the summer program starts in June,
so that's June to August.
And this year, we're thinking
about 20 hours per week,
and I'll talk a little bit
more as to what that entail.
For students who are
interested in LAB Jumpstart,
you have to commit to the full program.
So it is a large commitment.
And so we wanna make
sure that the students
that are joining us are
very much into doing so,
are very interested, are super engaged,
and are passionate about learning more.
All right, so what are our goals?
So one of the goals for LAB Jumpstart
is we wanna provide high school students
a positive, successful science experience
under the guidance of supportive
and compassionate mentors.
And so that would be RockEDU team,
we also have a number of
advocates that will be involved,
and I'll talk a little bit
more as to what that is,
and we also have two
facilitators of the program
who are graduate students who we mentor
throughout this process.
So we wanna make sure that
the students that we bring in
feel included or they
feel that they belong
in order for us to give
them the positive experience
that they may not have
otherwise seen in STEM.
We also wanna help high school students
to gain professional
skills for their future
in terms of academic and career pursuits.
So one thing we always like to say
is that a lot of times, students
may be interested in STEM
or have a passion for STEM.
They're not quite sure,
but it's something about
STEM that gets them going.
And so we're not really
interested in making sure
that these students go into a STEM career,
even though that would be amazing,
but we wanna make sure
that they're equipped
for whatever their
future academic or career
looks like in the future.
So we wanna make sure
that they're ready to go
for college applications,
that they feel secure
when they enter college.
And they feel secure going into any field
that they feel like they
wanna enter outside of STEM.
Hopefully it is in STEM.
So like I mentioned, our Jumpstart 2021
is actually going to be virtual.
So we've always had it in our laboratory.
The students would come in
to Rockefeller University
Tuesdays and Thursdays after school,
they'll be here from 4:30 to 7,
and they'll have dinner with us,
we'll take them into the lab,
we'll teach them all these great things.
It was very much an engaging
and hands on experience.
In March, the pandemic is still happening,
but it started in the New York area,
the United States worldwide.
And so we had to quickly revamp
our programming to virtual.
And so last year was, this year
was actually the first time
we've gone through the virtual
process of LAB Jumpstart.
And because everyone is unsure
of what the future may look like,
we're actually gonna go ahead
with doing LAB Jumpstart virtual for 2021.
So what would that look like?
And so these sessions
will still take place
after school during the spring.
They will all be through Zoom meetings.
Most of the courses will be synchronous.
So we'll be meeting together
on Tuesdays and Thursdays
from four to six.
There may be some classes
where you can do asynchronous work,
but we'll give you the time
outside of the Tuesdays
and Thursdays to do so.
So we might meet for a shorter time
on Tuesdays and Thursday
with expectations of you
fulfilling what you need to
do in that hour timeframe.
The spring session will be
from March 2nd to June 17th,
so the majority of the spring.
And this year, we have
two graduate students,
they're both from the
Laboratory of Social Evolution,
and actually do a lot of work with ants,
which is really fascinating.
And so they really look
at how evolutionary things
work in terms of social,
in terms of our social interactions,
and we can actually figure out
a lot of how that navigated
from ants even to human,
so how they work together,
how they're able to collab.
And these two graduate
students are really engaged
with the student body,
they're really engaged,
and they're very much interested
in teaching and mentoring students.
And so these sessions
will consist of lectures,
discussions, workshops, we'll have panels,
and we're also gonna have hands on work.
So what we've tried this year is that
and what we will be
doing this year is that
we're gonna be sending kits to students,
and these will be mailed to you.
All of these are approved
by our Environmental Health
and Safety Department
here at Rockefeller.
So everything that we send to
you will be able to be used
in your homes or whatever the
environment is that you're in.
Students will also be paired
with a scientist advocate.
And so what that is, is a scientist here
at Rockefeller University,
who will be there to advocate for you
outside of the program.
So they're there to provide
guidance and mentorship
in terms of things like communication,
if you have presentations to do,
helping you write your college essay,
fine tuning your resume,
any career advice that you're looking for.
So we're really hoping
that these scientists
will be there as an additional support
for you outside of the RockEDU team
and outside of the core facilitators.
So I just wanna briefly introduce
our two LAB Jumpstart
facilitators for 2021.
So on the left, we have Taylor Hart,
and Taylor studies in neurobiology
of how ants perceive pheromones,
and is working on developing tools
for studying these different
societies that ants have.
And Lindsey Lopes will be joining us
for the first time in 2021.
And Lindsey studies how ants
communicate with each other
by using chemical signals,
and how the ant brain is able
to process these chemicals
and coordinate with their behavior.
And so Taylor is actually
been with us this year.
So it would be her first time
or her second time
joining us for next year.
So she's what we call our,
I guess, senior facilitator,
and Lindsey will be joining us
for the first time this year.
But they both work in the same laboratory,
they both work really well together.
So I'm looking forward to an amazing year
with the two facilitators.
And they just love mentoring,
they have a passion for teaching,
so I'm really excited about that.
And so I just want to share some quotes
and I know a lot of people are hesitant
with everything virtual.
We're going through like Zoom
fatigue and pandemic fatigue.
And we really want to get out there,
but we really wanna make sure
that all of our students are safe.
And so these quotes are coming
from LAB Jumpstart students this year,
who did have to transition to virtual.
And so one of their feedback was that,
"RockEDU was good at getting
me out of my comfort zone
when speaking to new people.
Through LAB Jumpstart and SSRP virtual,"
which is our summer
portion of the program,
"I have learned to speak more openly."
So through LAB Jumpstart,
we really trying to get
students' confidence
to a level where they feel
comfortable speaking to people,
they feel comfortable doing presentations.
We work a lot with
doing oral presentations
or even learning how to
read scientific articles,
and how to present that
information to others.
Another quote from another student is,
"The Jumpstart program was
exactly the kind of science
that I enjoyed doing."
And I'm really hoping
that we can facilitate
the same type of thing
with our students in 2021,
where we bring the science to you
in a way that's humanizing and
trying to link both science
and human and the process
and how that all entails
to make the world go round.
And so I'm really hoping
that students this year
find it just as fascinating
as students last year did.
So in terms of the summer session,
so the spring, like I mentioned,
would go from March to June
and so that would be the two hours
on every Tuesdays and Thursdays.
And these hours are
outside of the holidays,
and the days off that the DOE has.
So we're working around the DOE calendar.
So we're not meeting during spring break,
and we're not meeting on holidays.
Now the summer program is gonna run
from June 28 to August 12,
with the exception of July 4th holiday.
And so you're expected to
work about 20 hours a week,
and this is both synchronous
and asynchronous work,
and you'll be doing
something along the lines
of what the scientific process looks like.
And so we'll be giving, sending kits
that you can do science in your spaces.
And so we're asking all students
who are involved in the spring program,
to also participate in the summer session,
where you'll take part in core sessions,
where we are able to
contextualize the relationship
between science and society.
We're hoping to promote critical thinking.
All of the students will be
placed in small group tracks.
And so within each track,
we actually have a team
of mentors and scientists
that are there to work with elements
of your research project.
So they're the ones that
kinda heading your project,
but you're kind of like the the brain
around developing this
project into something that
and looks great is relative
to different people.
And so we also host a variety of events
to promote networking, we
engage in relevant discussions,
we had a lot of talk about the pandemic,
we had talks about the
Black Lives Matter movement,
we had talks about being a person
who may not feel like
they're seen in the space.
So we really try to connect
you with different things.
We had a career panel this year,
showing the diversity of faces in science
and the scientific enterprise.
We had people who were MDs, PhDs,
people who are physical therapists.
So we really wanna find ways to connect
with students outside of the hard science,
but also build around that
experience and have fun.
I feel like we tend to forget that.
We think that it's school
and it's something to build
on our thinking and our knowledge
and we tend to leave fun up.
But RockEDU tries really
hard to incorporate fun
in everything we do.
We actually have an
impromptu group that comes in
and we do these acting things over Zoom,
which at first sounded weird,
but it was actually an amazing experience.
And so what do these
research tracks look like?
And so these research tracks are tailored
to what the scientists
are gonna bring forward.
So our scientists are actually
gonna start developing
these research tracks in December.
And so by June, everything is
put together and fine tuned,
and we're able to send
you all the science kits
to each students.
We survey all of our students to ensure
that whatever kits we're sending
is suitable for the
environment that you're in.
So we wanna make sure that everyone
feels like they're included.
We wanna make sure that everyone
has an equal opportunity
to do what they're interested in.
And so these materials
will be mailed to you.
I believe last year, we did FedEx,
you'll get it in a few days.
You don't need any prior
research experience.
This is something that
you come in open-minded
just ready to dive right in.
And I think what I really
love about this method
of doing science is that
you have the ability
to put your own design and
your own knowledge to it.
So instead of being in a
laboratory, where you're taking,
don't wanna say orders
where you're taking orders
from the teacher and the laboratory,
you're kind of just taking this kit
and molding it into what you
feel that it should grow into.
And so you have a lot of autonomy
over the work that you're doing,
and you have mentors
that are rooting for you,
and a diverse amount of trainees
that are here to help you out.
So some of the tracks
that we had last year
and some of the themes
that surrounded that,
we had our RNA Bioinformatics,
and our Protein Structure and
Alzheimer's research track,
and those were more so computer-based
and like programming-based.
We also had a microbiology.
We had two tracks under microbiology.
So we had a yeast and bacteria track
where students were able to cultivate
these microbes safely in their homes.
And we also had an ant
social biology track
where students had the option
of observing ants in the
wild or capturing ants
and developing experimental
studies on that.
So what do students get out of it?
What do you get out of it?
And so if you're not convinced
that this might be the program for you,
for the students that are listening in,
this is, once again, I'm gonna reiterate
that it is college and career support.
So at the end, we see that
you've put in the best effort,
you seem super passionate
from the beginning to the end,
you're definitely more than happy,
and we beg you to access the
letters of recommendation
that can be from the RockEDU team
or that can be from your research mentors,
or it can be from the
facilitators from the program.
Each one of you or each
one of the students
that get into the program
will be assigned an advocate.
And this is like you have
your own science person
that you can connect with.
And so it's kind of like
having a scientist at hand
where you can call if
you have any questions
outside of your project
if you need help with
anything that you're doing,
and if they don't know how to help you,
we can find means and ways
to provide that help for you.
You're gonna be a group
with other students
who are like-minded as yourself.
So all these science nerds coming together
to have a really great time.
We take in 16 students and we try our best
to make our virtual LAB Jumpstart
as engaging as possible.
So you're not only engaging
with the scientists
and the facilitators and the mentors,
but you're also engaging with the students
that are involved in this process.
More importantly, this
is laying the foundation
for your network in STEM.
You're gonna meet amazing students,
you're gonna meet amazing scientists,
you're gonna meet amazing mentors,
and so they're gonna
definitely help build.
For all of our LAB Jumpstart students,
we help you build your LinkedIn website.
So it's like the start of
your professional world.
And even more importantly, you
get paid for your commitment.
So we know this is a
larger commitment time,
but it's definitely worth it.
But we're also paying 2,250 stipend
that will cover the spring and the summer,
just to reflect the amount of
time that you've committed.
We don't want any
students to have to choose
between having a summer job
or being involved in something
that they're passionate
about, such as science.
So really finding ways to
break down those barriers,
and we're hoping that a stipend
can help alleviate that.
So if you're interested
and you want to apply,
there are some important
dates to keep in mind.
So October 5th, so a couple of weeks ago,
nominations are open,
so you do need to be
nominated by an adult.
Once you're nominated by an adult,
the application would open for you
and you can begin your application.
Nominations end on December 21st.
And so after nominations close,
you won't be able to get
someone to nominate you,
but the applications would
close on January 4th.
So even on the last day
of you getting nominated,
you have a few weeks to
get your application in.
What does application process look like?
So step one, like I mentioned,
if you're interested,
find someone to nominate you.
Once you're nominated,
you're gonna get a link
to start your application,
and that would be sent to
the email that you gave.
Once you get that application
and you finish your application,
it's submitted, it's
reviewed by our staff,
grad students, facilitators.
And out of that group of applications,
we bring in about 20, well, this time,
we're bringing you in through Zoom,
and about 20 students will
be interviewed virtually.
From the batch of about 20 students,
we'll pick 16 to move forward
through the LAB Jumpstart program.
Once you finish your
interview, by February,
you'll be notified on your status.
And so you'll get an email indicating
whether or not you got in or
if to apply again another time.
We'll also give you other opportunities
that you can apply to if you
did not get into LAB Jumpstart.
There are some several components involved
in the application.
You will need to submit
a personal statement.
You also need to provide a
commentary on a scientific study.
We'll provide the article
for you in the application.
You also need to provide a resume
and an unofficial transcript
and two letters of recommendations.
And so who's eligible?
So once again, you just have
to be nominated by an adult
and this can be anyone.
It can be your teacher, (coughs) sorry,
it could be a teacher, your mentor,
your pastor, your choir director,
someone who can attest to
who you are as a person,
your passion for the sciences.
You must be aged 16 years or older
by the start of LAB Jumpstart,
so that's March 2nd.
There are no exceptions to that rule.
You must attend a school in New York City
and you must commit to the entirety
of the program and that's
from March 2nd to August 12th.
And on the right here,
you just have some of our
past LAB Jumpstart students
from the 2020 cohort.
So do we did a Flipgrid assignment
where we were able to talk about
what LAB Jumpstart meant to everyone.
And as you can see, they
look like they had a blast,
as I'm sure that they did.
So now I'm gonna open up
the lines for questions.
Any concerns?
Before I go into it, I just
wanna quickly point out
our team once again.
So myself, Odaelys Pollard,
the scientist educator here.
We have our director, Jeanne Garbarino,
our administrator, Doug Heigl,
Disan Davis, who's our program
manager and Lizzie Krisch,
who is our program coordinator.
Also follow us, our team on Instagram,
and if you have Twitter,
we're there as well.
Here's some of our other information.
So you can go, we have our website
where we have online resources.
mostly for educators and it's RockEDU
and outreach professionals,
rockedu.rockefeller.edu.
Our email, if you have any other questions
that you may not have the
opportunity to ask today,
you can reach out to us at
outreach@rockefeller.edu.
And follow us, if you have a cell phone,
if you're on a computer,
you can scan the QR code.
And I think that'll bring
you up to our newsletter
or application, I'm not sure actually.
- Awesome, so we have
a couple of questions
about things like how
do we choose applicants?
How many people apply?
Are we flexible on the age requirements?
- So yeah, so when you're joining
the LAB Jumpstart program,
you cannot just join the spring session,
you have to join for the
entirety of the session.
So one of the questions that
we asked in the interviews
whether or not you can
commit to the entire time.
So it's not a program that split into two,
it's a program with two parts,
if that makes sense.
So you're unable to join if
you can only join for one part.
Yes, so there are no
exceptions with the age.
So you have to be 16 by March
2nd, that's not an us rule.
That's a legal Rockefeller
University rule.
There is the separate application
for the summer program.
So for students who just wanna participate
in the Summer Science Research
Program, you can do so.
You don't need a nomination for that,
you can just start an application.
And I think those application,
the deadline for that
is the same, January 4th
or December 21st, I can't
remember, I have to double check.
But it's either December or January.
So if things are opened up,
we will be meeting in-person?
Probably not, so we've gone
back and forth on this,
like what the pandemic may
look like in the future.
We're hoping that maybe we can do
like a quick meet and greet
outside outdoors some way.
But the chances were planning
for us to not meet in-person.
It's just easier for us as a team
to plan your projects ahead of time,
instead of waiting to see whether or not
we can bring you all on campus.
We're almost 100% sure that
we still won't be allowed
to have visitors on campus
at that time indoors.
For working papers, send us an email,
and we can talk more about that.
So we're actually working on
project development right now.
So we actually have a
program of scientists
that will be working on
developing the summer projects
and the spring projects.
And so we actually won't
have a finalized project list
until the spring and the summer.
One thing I just wanna note
is despite of the project,
the process is pretty much the same.
We really zone in and focus on
what science is as a process.
So in terms of your inspiration
for starting a project, right?
Observing, exploring,
asking the questions,
coming up with some of your
results in your conclusions,
delivering this message.
Talking about iteration
of your project, failing,
how do you handle that failure?
Because science is, I
wanna say 90% failure,
and 10% success,
but that's kind of what
makes science science.
What would make your
application stand out?
So we look for several things.
We look for keen interest,
your passion for sciences,
making sure that you can
commit to that entire time.
We do not look at grades.
What we do look at is, have
you improved in your grade,
so maybe you have like a bad
year, your 10th grade year.
But your teacher wrote a
letter of recommendation
and explained like,
you may have had
difficulties in the subject,
you worked really hard,
they're really into it,
and we think that they'll be successful
in a program, that's fine.
We're not looking for straight A students.
I don't expect you to have a 4.0,
but I do expect you to work hard
to be successful in the program.
So the themes of this year's research.
For the spring, it will be more so
of talking about the scientific process
within the scientific enterprise.
So the project's would
look pretty much the same
for everyone in the spring.
The summer, people would be
off in their smaller projects,
in their mentored group.
And so what we do prior
to the summer session
is once we get the idea of the
projects and what it entails,
we'll send out a survey,
and we'll try our best to match students
based on their needs and
wants for that summer.
So in terms of like space that you have,
access to certain things, your interest,
we try to take all of
that into consideration
when we're matching students
into these project groups.
For letters of recommendation,
would it be preferred if the
adults writing the letter?
No, you can have a
letter of recommendation
from anyone that can
attest to your willingness
to be a part of the program.
Of course, having a science teacher
can really give us an
idea of like how much
you're really into the science,
but it definitely doesn't have to be.
And then we know as well,
like this year, it's weird.
Like in terms of schooling,
we know many teachers may
not have that relationship
with you like they've had before.
And we wanna make sure that students
who still want the
opportunity to be involved
in this program can do so without having
a teacher's recommendation
or a nomination per se.
No, so once you enter the program,
the program is spring and summer.
So you can't just enter for the spring
and you can't just enter for the summer.
If you just wanna be a
part of the summer program,
which is a more competitive program.
So the summer program, we get applications
from all over the world, so
it's not strictly NYC students.
So it makes it a lot more competitive
and they're not necessarily
students from the NYC area
or from more underserved areas.
And so the Jumpstart program,
we started as a precursor program
to make sure that we still get students
who are definitely
interested in doing science
and may not have been
giving those opportunities
like some of the other
students in the summer.
But if you think you have
a strong application,
we're more than happy for you to apply
to the summer program outside
of the Jumpstart program.
(indistinct)
So it depends, so do we
submit the summer application
when the time comes
even if we get accepted?
If you got accepted
into the spring program,
you don't need to apply
to the summer program.
And so what happens is LAB Jumpstart,
this cohort of 16 students
are given the tools
and supports that we
think that they would need
to be successful in the summer program.
So in the summer, these
students may have already been
in a laboratory before they may have done
some type of science research project,
they may have even authored
a scientific paper before
and a lot of times, this
may come from opportunities
that they may have been given
outside of other students
who may not have received
those same opportunities.
And so the Jumpstart program
is our precursor program
to give you all the extra
support that you need
to make sure that when you
get into the summer program
that you feel like you're equipped,
and you feel like you can be successful
in that summer program.
So we're really looking
for a different type
of student group, I
would say in the spring,
than we're looking for the summer,
but we wanna make sure
that the spring time,
the students that starts in the spring
can definitely breeze on in
through the summer program.
Did I miss any other questions?
- [Jeanne] Did you get
the one, the difference
between the spring and...
There was a question of
what is the difference
between the spring and summer program,
but I think, I'm not
sure if that means this.
Oh, that's what you just answered, sorry-
- Summer program is a Summer
Science Research Program.
And so that's another application.
So there are two different applications.
The Jumpstart program which
includes spring and summer,
and then there's the Summer
Science Research Program,
which is just the summer.
Also to note the summer program,
there's not a stipend involved with that
unless it's a need-based stipend.
All of our Jumpstart programs
will receive a stipend
that will cover the spring and the summer.
So the spring program,
we're definitely looking for students
that's coming from
under-resourced schools.
Hence, why we made it just New York City,
usually students are
coming from public schools
in New York City.
Are looking for students
who are super passionate
about science, super
passionate about the subject,
just did not get the opportunity
to work in a laboratory before
or did not get the opportunity
to do some type of
science research before,
and want to get their
feet wet in that process.
And so we've developed
the Jumpstart program
to target those student groups.
Yeah, are there any.
Does each project encompass knowledge
from a specific branch of science?
Yeah, kinda. So science is very broad.
So like I mentioned, the
four different projects
that we had last summer,
we had one, that was bioinformatics.
So, and it was bioinformatics
in terms of looking at
genetic information from,
I believe, it was COVID patients.
And so you're learning a
little bit about the biology,
but it was a lot more of computing
in terms of using bioinformatic
programs on your computer,
such as the name is escaping
me, BLAST, NCBI BLAST,
you're using other programming
that help you line up sequences.
The Alzheimer's program was
more of a structural program.
So you're using programs that allowed you
to look at the structures
of different proteins
that this particular lab was looking like.
So you needed the knowledge of Alzheimer's
and neurodegenerative disease,
but you also get the knowledge
of programming itself.
The microbiology research projects
were more so understanding bacteria
as a community of microbes,
understanding how to
cultivate and analyze,
developing experiments, using agar plates
and culturing them in
your home and your spaces.
So they're all from
different fields of science,
and it's mostly dependent on the expertise
of scientists here at Rockefeller.
So if you wanna get an idea of the science
that's done here at Rockefeller,
you can visit rockefeller.edu,
and you can see the list of
laboratories that are here
and just do a little bit of reading
and also help to maybe pique your interest
in some type of science
that you not necessarily
may have thought of like
an area of science before.
So I definitely recommend going on there
and just browsing around
the different laboratories
and some of the science that they do.
Projects, what time.
The time commitment during the spring,
so it's Tuesdays and Thursdays
after school from 4 to 6 p.m.
So I don't think every class
will be for those two hours.
We wanna be mindful that
you've been on Zoom all day,
and you really wanna try to find projects
and things that you
can do outside of Zoom.
So we're working really hard this year
to try to develop something
that's interactive and hands on,
hence why we're hoping
to send you all kits
that you can be doing
some projects in your home
without having to be on on
Zoom for the entire time.
Ooh, you're interested in
the field of mathematics?
Is it a good program to join?
I feel like math is related
to science, but I'm biased.
I don't know. What do you think, Jeanne?
- [Jeanne] Yes, yes, there are
definitely research projects
that involve some elements of math.
There's a lot of even wet
lab or image processing
or other types of computer-based work
that you can certainly relate to math.
If you're looking for
a full-on math program,
I do not think that this
would be a good fit,
but if you're looking to
find and work on things
that have increased chances
for integrating math
with some sort of biological
phenomenon or concept,
there are certainly possibilities there,
modeling, other things like that.
- Yeah, so we actually
have scientists here
who have done like an
undergraduate degree in mathematics
and work in laboratories here
in the biological sciences.
So if you're looking for
ways to integrate your love
for math and science, and
yes, like Jeanne mentioned,
if you're looking for
like hard, hard math,
probably won't be the program for you.
Can you make up missing work?
So depends on what that means.
So we're hoping that Jumpstart
is not like a homework program.
So if you're thinking of missing classes,
we really hope that you're
able to join us on every class,
because it's gonna be really hard for us
to, I guess, provide that class
for you outside of the class.
What we will do is record each session
so that if something does
occur, where you do have to,
you can't show up on that day,
and we're very lenient
in terms of understanding
like your personal life
and things that may happen,
we're fine with you
missing a couple of days.
If it's like a string of like absences,
then maybe we should reconsider
your involvement in the program.
But if you miss a day or two,
we'll have that Zoom session recorded,
and we'll probably be using a platform,
such as Google Classroom to post things
in terms of like reminders for the week,
here's a Zoom recording
in case you missed it,
or you wanted to go through a refresher.
You'll have a syllabus
as well to figure out
what the following weeks may look like.
... high school students attending.
Oh, yeah, are underrepresented minorities
given a preference?
Yeah, so we're looking
for underrepresented,
underserved students from
under-resourced schools.
So yeah, that's pretty much
who the program is for.
Going some stuff, can you
submit any additional...
Yeah, so under application,
there's a space that allows
you to send something
that you think that we may not ask,
that you think would help
your application in terms of,
this is me, but I also wanna
show you another part of me
and I can't really show that
through the other items in application.
So if you have something
else that you wanna showcase,
yes, please link that to the application.
And if I'm not wrong, Doug, I
feel like on the application,
there's a space for them to upload
an additional file if they need to.
- [Doug] Yeah, yeah,
we have space for some,
I mean, we do like, just want
a writing sample as well.
But other things are
definitely able to be included,
we wanna see who you are.
- Are all research tracks
just biological-based
or they focus on the fields
of chemistry and physics?
So like I mentioned, we're not sure
what the actual research
tracks would look like as yet.
We do have scientists here
that work in all three,
so there are biological sciences,
there's chemistry, there's physics.
So I mentioned if you go on
the website and just browse
what these labs are doing
can give you an idea of
what the possibilities are
in terms of research tracks.
Will the project entail an
in-depth analysis of data
and scientific gathering of information?
What exactly do you mean by that?
So do you mean like, would it
be more data analysis space?
All the projects,
we're hoping that you
can get data from it.
Part of the process is analyzing the data,
and so it depends on the project
and what that data
analysis will look like.
But every project will have some type
of data analysis entailed.
And every project would
require you to either learn
the scientific information
to successfully do that
through the mentors or through papers
that your mentors may share.
All these projects will be giving you
the background information
and the scientific knowledge
that you would need to be successful
in developing the data sets that you have,
and analyzing that data set.
Alongside the summer program
and we'll do it through the spring,
we'll have other scientists
talking about other types of science.
So in our summer program,
we have a lot of science adjacent.
So we have laboratories
that would talk to you all
about the work that they do in their labs,
the type of science that they're doing.
So it might be like
categorization, evolution,
just standard experimental modeling,
and so you'll get a taste of every,
not every type of science,
but you get a taste of the
broad scientific enterprise
outside of just your project.
so it's a really good opportunity
to not only do something in your groups,
but also to learn about other types
of science and fields.
Will we be able to form connections
with people in the science field
that could possibly help us?
Yeah, so for the Jumpstart program,
like I mentioned, we have our advocates.
And so our Jumpstart advocates
are there to do just that.
And so we're hoping that
they will be the ones
who can help you with
your college applications.
And so you'll be given
their email addresses,
they'll be checking in on you,
find out where you are in the
college application process,
if they can find someone else
who may be able to help you,
if we can find someone, we're
more than happy to do so.
We wanna make sure that all
of our Jumpstart scholars
are successful in that
college application process
and also successful in college.
We always ask our Jumpstart
scholars to stay in touch
so we can help in terms of networking
and getting you the people that you need
to help you wherever you are.
Do we work in teams or as a class? Both.
So there may be some sessions
where we're working
together in a large group.
So say on a Tuesday, we'll be
talking about the background
or giving you some type of knowledge,
will be like interactive lecture,
and then we might split
you off into breakout rooms
to work together as a team.
You definitely have to work in
teams, you can't bypass that.
So even if you feel like you
don't like to work in teams,
it will be a thing that you'll
learn during this process,
which will be very helpful
outside of LAB Jumpstart
and the summer program.
So we'll be doing both team
and class, team and class.
For the list of laboratories,
only four of them will be picked
to be the theme of research tracks?
We're not picking like a specific four,
we're kinda developing
based on the expertise
of the labs that we have.
I don't know if Jeanne
wants to add to that.
- [Jeanne] Yeah, so
basically, how it works
is we we develop a pool of mentors
that want to participate on research team.
And each of those people,
even though they're coming from a variety,
they're coming from a
variety of different labs,
we might have a lab,
we might have a postdoc
who studies skin cancer,
who studies DNA evolution,
something like that, right?
So everybody's coming in
with having studied different topics.
But what we do is we figure
out what types of skills
they might have that overlap.
So for example, we might
have a group of scientists
who are really good at doing
modeling and bioinformatics
in a variety of different ways.
So we might put them together
to create a bioinformatics track, right?
Or for example, in the yeast track,
Odaelys and I both have a
background in microbiology,
and we were the main facilitators
for the Wild Yeast Track.
And we brought in experts to
help out with image analysis.
We brought in experts to help out
with just general yeast culture,
and also some modeling using
our using R studio, right?
So the projects emerge based
on the collective skill sets
of the scientists who are coming in
to participate as mentors.
And the reason why we're
not able to tell you
about that right now is
because the mentors are not,
we don't get them together
until March or so,
'cause we have to give scientists time
to think about their projects
and also determine their availabilities.
So, those topics will
certainly be more developed
and transparent to the Jumpstart students
sometime in middle to late spring.
I hope that's an adequate
answer for your question,
and thank you for this.
- There was another question,
did we answered it already?
So for this, so we're not
looking to give homework.
We're hoping that whatever we give you all
would be that four hours a week.
So whether that's two
hours on Tuesday over Zoom
and two hours on Tuesday over,
two hours on Tuesdays and two
hours on Thursdays over Zoom
or an hour over Zoom
and an hour assignment,
an hour or half an hour in Zoom,
an hour and a half assignment,
we're hoping that the
amount of participation,
amount of hours that
you need to participate
will be that four hours a
week, so we're not giving,
we're not meeting for four hours,
and then telling you to go
home and do an extra four hours
in preparation to come back next week
and do another like eight
hours, if that makes sense.
If there's any types of homework
or be like more so your enrichment,
so maybe it wasn't something
that was quite clear,
and you wanted to go back
over to Zoom recording,
or you wanted to reach
out about a clarification,
or you wanted to do some
extra reading on your own,
that's fine, but we're not necessarily...
it's not, we're staying away
from it being a classroom, right?
So this whole program is not us lecturing
to you over Zoom, it's
gonna be discussion-based,
it's gonna be engaging,
it's gonna be hands on,
it's gonna be talking
about science as a whole.
And this is also going alongside,
like what Jeanne was mentioning is that,
I wouldn't put too much focus
on the projects themselves
because one misconception is that,
"Oh, I'm interested in bacteria, right?
And that's the only
thing I'm interested in.
And if I don't get that bacterial project,
I'm not taking part."
When in actuality, I might do
a project on muscles, right?
And a lot of the skills that I'm doing
with this project on muscles,
I can transfer to the
skills that I would need
to work on that project with bacteria.
So we're really looking at
more of like the process
that it takes to do a science project
in terms of critical thinking,
in terms of thinking about a
problem, analyzing a problem,
what techniques, what skills that you need
to be successful in that,
how do you navigate through
failing in this experiment?
How do I navigate analyzing
a specific data set, right?
Like Jeanne and Disan, or
whoever else was in the lab,
we may have all done
three different things,
but we came together to realize
that we have many of the same tool kits
and many of the same skill sets
that allowed us to transfer those skills
towards something completely different
than what we had done in the laboratory.
So I really want students to focus in
on we're not just teaching
you about one specific thing,
we're teaching you how to
be successful scientists,
successful thinkers in the future.
And that would definitely come into play
when outside of school,
when you go to college,
and if you decide to pursue a STEM career.
So don't be too bogged down
on like what you think
the topic is gonna be.
You're gonna get the information
and we're gonna make it as engaging
and interesting as we can given the Zoom.
I would say that in terms
of large time commitment,
I feel like it is a commitment.
So if you have other things
happening outside of school,
you might have to pick and
choose what you wanna do.
So one thing I ask students
is to make sure like,
I understand that you
might have extracurricular,
but we also need to make sure
that you will fully
participate in the program.
So if you're doing like
soccer after school,
you're also in a music program,
and you're tutoring, right?
You may have to consider if you can handle
doing all four things
or you may have to put
something to the side
for one semester and
take on this opportunity
and then go back to it the next semester.
So I definitely don't
recommend trying to juggle
more than, I would say,
two extracurricular,
if you're gonna do Jumpstart.
With that, you do need
to be present and there
for this program in
order to be successful.
We have taken Catholic
school students in Jumpstart,
so feel free to apply as well.
So we don't give college
credits for this program.
What I think what's even
better than college credits
is the letter of recommendation
that you're gonna get.
So I've actually,
I don't know if this
means anything to anyone,
but we've had former
students from both Jumpstart
and SSRP that are going
into science careers
in terms of like becoming
a physician assistant.
Some are going to
outreach, some are in labs.
We have students going into Yale, Harvard,
a lot of them have stayed local
and going to universities here.
In terms of like the SSRP,
the summer program itself,
I've actually had physicians who told me
that they were part of the summer program.
So even though you're not
getting that summer credit,
I think you're getting
invaluable experiences
through the Jumpstart program
that you can take with you beyond college.
No, you have to commit to
the spring and the summer.
So for students who can't
commit to the summer,
we don't recommend that
you apply to the program.
We do need to full commitment for both,
the March through August,
so it's not something that we can split.
Thank you.
Yeah, it's more of a research opportunity,
yeah, with other added benefits,
but you're also gonna learn things
that would aid in your academics.
So I've also had Jumpstart students who,
we cover a specific topic,
and they return a couple weeks after
and said that the teacher just
went over something similar.
And they were able to quickly catch on
to what their teacher was saying
because they were given
an overview of it here at Jumpstart.
So even though it is a
research opportunity,
it does help in your academic,
but I would say it's more so research
with other things that can aid
in your professional development.
Can you apply to both Jumpstart
and the summer program?
Yeah, you can.
Do you think showing that we were a part
of this program might boost?
Oh, yeah, definitely.
So getting into Ivy
Leagues, like I mentioned,
we have several students that have gone
into Ivy League school after participating
in Jumpstart and SSRP.
I think RockEDU is a well-known program
in terms of student
programming that we have here.
And like I mentioned,
the name and the letters of recommendation
can take you a very long way.
And this is also based on your commitment.
Like you can't say,
"Hey, I wanna be a part of this program
because I know it will
help me in the future."
Your letter of recommendation
is also based on what you put in, right?
You can't expect your
mentors and your facilitators
to write you a great recommendation
if you did not put in
the effort and the work
that they felt that you should have had.
- [Jeanne] Yeah, and if I
can add to that, Odaelys,
I'll just add some data to
support you in sharing that.
We have had students from
LAB Jumpstart attend Harvard,
MIT, Brandeis-
- Barnard.
- [Jeanne] Barnard.
- Full scholarships.
- [Jeanne] What's the one in
Chicago? University of Chicago.
Oh, Yale, we've had a couple of Yales.
We've also had really
awesome Macaulay Honors,
Hunter College, a couple
of our CUNY schools,
which are fantastic city college.
- BU.
- [Jeanne] BU, yeah, our
students are definitely,
it's correlation and
causation, this is something.
Oh, yeah, we've had Columbia.
- Columbia, yep.
- [Jeanne] Absolutely, so
correlation and causation
is something that we'll
go very deeply into
on our discussions, but we
are certainly correlated
with very, very well-known
and highly respected universities so.
- Yeah, so can we mention...
Does this program itself
offer any scholarships?
The scholarship that we're
offering is the stipend.
I don't think that answered the question.
Let's see, if we choose to
follow a different career path
in the future than science,
can we still do the program?
Well, we're hoping to have students
that are interested in doing science.
So if you come into the program saying
that this is something
that you're interested in,
"I really enjoy STEM.
I'm just not sure if it's right for me.
I haven't had the opportunity
to get my feet wet."
We want you to apply.
If you know from the get go
that you don't even enjoy
sitting in your science class,
I probably won't apply to LAB Jumpstart.
So Jumpstart program and the SSRP program
are two different programs.
Jumpstart students are
automatically entered
into the summer program,
if that makes sense.
So that's why there's
two application process.
There are two different types
of student groups as well,
like I mentioned, the Jumpstart program
are for students who were
not afforded the opportunity
to get involved into research.
So they're usually students
from New York City DOE schools,
students from underserved communities.
So for example, we've had
like first gen students.
We've had students who may have gone
to a Catholic school who
just moved to the US.
We've had students who, I don't know,
what are some other examples?
They're all students who are part
of the New York City School System
that were not giving opportunities
that other students may have had,
and those students usually apply to LAB,
I mean, to Summer Science
Research Program or SSRP.
So Rockefeller University
does not have an
undergraduate institution,
it's a graduate school.
I also wanna throw it out there,
The Rockefeller University
is one of the best research
institution in the US.
So that alone puts a lot of weight
on your participation in the program.
Like I mentioned,
students who are applying
to these programs should be students
who are genuinely
interested in doing science.
If you know that you want
to go into accounting
or I don't know, what's
something not science-related?
Something that's not even close to-
- Theater.
- Theater, right?
If you do both, like you can
do arts and science, right?
If you're interested in theater,
which we had another student, Jacob,
who would go to theater
classes after Jumpstart,
or come to Jumpstart after
theater classes, right?
And now he's doing both in college.
If you're interested in both, apply.
If you're interested in theater
and not at all interested
in science, do not apply.
Yeah, so Jumpstart is only for NYC,
NYC, including all five boroughs,
Staten Island, Brooklyn,
Bronx, Manhattan, and Queens.
And I think the benefit
now of doing it virtually
is that you don't have to commute.
We've had students
commuting from Staten Island
every Tuesday and Thursday after school.
And so it just shows that how committed
these students were to participating.
I have students coming
from Red Hook and Brooklyn
coming to Jumpstart after school,
students who have to
commute to Coney Island.
And so I think it's really nice
that you won't have to
travel an hour and a half
to two hours to get here.
So it definitely opens up the opportunity
to be involved in something
that you don't have to travel all the way
to the Upper East Side to participate in.
Yeah, so if you know, like I mentioned,
if you know you're in a school
that has like an A1 science program,
you have a lab in your school,
you've done PCR already,
you've may have worked
in a lab in the summer,
you have a connection to something else,
you've done science fairs like 20 times,
and you've won first place,
and you've gone on to the nationals,
Jumpstart is probably
not the program for you.
You'll definitely be a
competitive applicant
for the summer program,
so I'd apply to the Summer
Science Research Program.
We're really looking for
students in Jumpstart
who we can give the extra support
and the supplies that we
think would allow them
to be successful in
the competitive program
during the summer.
Is all the work hands on?
When I say...
(indistinct) to apply our knowledge.
- [Jeanne] I just put up an
answer in the chat, yeah.
Yeah, we really want there
to be an appreciation
for science as an
element of everyday life.
But it's also important that
we do get into some theory,
but you will likely be more the hands on
than the purely theoretical.
- It depends on your involvement is.
If you worked like in a
summer program before,
like for an extended period of time,
then I would apply for the summer program.
If you like worked in a lab
like a lab as part of your class,
and you don't think that you
really got the opportunity
to dive in to science, then I
would say apply to Jumpstart.
- [Jeanne] This is such a
wonderful information session.
I'm so pumped that there's
all these awesome questions.
I'm sorry my video's not on, Odaelys,
'cause you didn't give me any permissions
to have my video on but-
- Oh, I didn't know I had to do it.
- [Lizzie] That was me, I think. Sorry.
- [Jeanne] I just wanted
to apologize for that.
Anyway, yeah. Is there
any other questions?
Does anybody have any other
questions? This is so exciting.
I hope that we get a ton of applications
and that we read all about you all,
both through the personal statement
and learn about your scientific interests,
and this is exciting.
- [Doug] I just want to really quickly say
that 'cause I know we've
gotten a few questions about,
which program do I apply to?
Don't freak out about, "Oh, I
applied to the wrong program."
We have moved students' applications
from either the Jumpstart path into SSRP
or from SSRP into Jumpstart
if we think that you
are a better candidate
for a particular pathway.
So don't overthink it too
much, don't worry too much.
We'll make sure you
get to the right place.
And if you have questions
on a case by case basis,
reach out, and we'll try to clarify.
- Yes, you can definite, we would love
if you can join the program,
apply to the program
if you love science and have an interest
and you wanna test it out. (giggles)
- [Jeanne] Yeah, I will add that.
I think one of the amazing things
that you can get out of Jumpstart is,
I mean, obviously, is a pathway
if you wanna go into science,
but I think just as importantly,
it gives you an opportunity
in a fairly low stakes way
relative to the rest of your life,
discover that maybe
you don't love science,
and I think that's okay, too.
So I just wanna push that out there.
We want you to feel successful,
that is our ultimate goal,
whether that means success means for you
that you start off and
pursue some sort of PhD
down the road, or maybe
success for you means
that you just had a
good time experimenting,
but you really wanna go
and be a lawyer, right?
That's okay, too, so we are here for you,
and we really wanna elevate
everyone's opportunities
to participate in an
authentic process of science.
- I agree.
- Yeah, so both programs are challenging.
Like I mentioned, if you feel
like you have all the tools
and you're a competitive applicant
and you're a straight A student,
I would apply to both programs
and see what that fits.
Might be that your application
can just go straight
through to summer program.
But yes, they will both
be challenging, I think.
I haven't had anyone say
that it was easy breezy.
It was fun, but we we try
our best to go into your,
I don't wanna say, go into your heads,
but we wanna try our best
to get your brain juices going, right?
Have you thinking about stuff,
thinking outside the box,
thinking critically,
thinking of science in a way
that may not have necessarily been the way
that it was taught in your classes.
Kind of like giving you a real view
of what science actually is
and what it takes to be involved
in that scientific process.
- Yes, we expect failure.
And in fact, we thrive and think
it's a necessary component.
So yes, the challenge will be present,
but it also, we will not
let it crush anybody either.
So that's a good, we're gonna
find that balance.
- All the support, yeah.
You have the support, we wanna
make sure we have sessions
where it's just about having fun, right?
We do like these impromptu session
where we have a group come in,
and we do like acting,
right, through the video.
We have time where we just
have conversations, right?
Maybe we take the first 15 minutes
and talk about like how's school going?
How's your mental health,
your emotional health?
Just to debrief, right?
Leaving with a quote of,
hey, this is something to feel good about.
This is something to think about.
And so we wanna make sure
that we're hitting all parts
of you as a person, and
doing that through science,
if that makes sense.
- Yeah, I'm just so like, I'm pumped up
by such an amazing showing,
and the questions are
non-stop that I just,
I'm gonna jump on my soapbox
one more time and say,
this program is designed
to support people.
And then once we have a
good support of people,
we show them how to do science, right?
We will never lose sight that
science is a human endeavor.
We want people to feel
good about themselves,
feel good about the science and excel,
be challenged, appreciate failure.
We are gonna make it pretty
difficult and challenging
for you at an academic level,
but we'll make sure that
you're being supported
in the other ways as best as
we can within our capacity.
Again, we wanna push you to do
the best you can possibly do,
and that is the goal.
- These are great questions.
Thank you all for coming in.
Thank you for your interest.
I'm hoping to see the
applications pour in.
I'm hoping to ponder
over many applications
to pick the chosen 16.